people use the internet for various
reasons it turns out that one of the
most popular categories of websites it's
something that people typically consume
in private it involves curiosity known
in significant level of self-indulgence
and send them around recording the
reproductive activities of other people
of course I'm talking about genealogy
the study of family history when it
comes to detailing family history in
every family we have this person that is
obsessed with genealogy let's call him
uncle Bernie uncle Bernie is exactly the
last person you want to sit next to in
Thanksgiving dinner because he will bore
you to death with peculiar details about
some ancient relatives but as you know
there is scientific side for everything
and we found that uncle Bernie's stories
have immense potential for biomedical
research we let uncle Bernie and his
fellow genealogists to document their
family trees through a genealogy website
called Genie calm when users upload
their twist to the website it scans the
relatives and if it find matches to
existing trees it merges the existing
and the new tree together the result is
that large family trees are created
beyond the individual level of each
genealogist now by repeating this
process with millions of people all over
the world we can crowd was the
construction of a family tree of all
humankind using this website we were
able to connect 125 million people into
a single family tree I cannot draw the
tree on the screens over here because
they have less pixels than the number of
people in this tree but here is an
example of a subset of 6,000 individuals
each green node is a person the red
nodes represent marriages and the
connections represent Parenthood in the
middle of this tree you see the
ancestors and as we go to the periphery
you see the descendants and this tree
has seven generations approximately now
this what happens when we increase the
number of individuals to seventy
thousand people still a tiny subset of
all the data that we have despite that
you can already see the formation of
gigantic family trees with very many
distant relatives thanks to the hard
work of our genealogists we can go back
in time hundreds of years ago for
example here is Alexander Hamilton that
was born in 1755 Alexander was the first
US Secretary of trail of Treasury but
mostly known today due to a popular
brother music musical we found that
Alexander has deeper connections in the
showbiz industry in fact is a blood
relative of Kevin Bacon both of them are
descendants of the lady from Scotland
who lived in the thirteenth century so
you can say that Alex
Alexander Hamilton has thirty five
degrees of Kevin Bacon genealogy and our
tree has millions of stories like that
we invested significant efforts to
validate the quality of our data using
DNA we found that point three percent of
the mother-child connections in our data
are wrong which could match the adoption
rate in the US pre second world war for
the father side the news are not as good
1.9 percent of the father child
connections in our data are wrong and a
system people smirk over here it is what
you think there are many milkman out
there however this 1.9 percent error
rate in patrilineal connections is not
unique to our data
previous studies found a similar error
rate using clinical grade pedigrees
the quality of our data is good and that
should not be a surprise our
genealogists have profound vested
interest in correctly incorrectly
documenting the family history we can
leverage this data to learn quantitative
information about humanity
for example questions about demography
here is a look of all of our profiles on
the map of the world each pixel is a
person that lived at some point and
since we have so much data you can see
the contours of many countries
especially in the Western world in this
clip we stratify the map that I showed
you based on the year of birth of
individuals from 1400 to 1900 and we
compared it to known migration events
the clip is going to show you that the
deepest lineages in our data go all the
way back to the UK where they had better
record-keeping and then they spread
along the roots of Western colonialism
let's watch this
[Music]
I love this movie now since this
migration events are given in the
context of families we can ask questions
such as what is the typical distance
between the birth locations of husbands
and wives this distance plays a pivotal
role in demography because the patterns
in which people migrate to form families
determine how genes spread in
geographical areas we analyze this
distance using our data and we found
that in the old days people additive him
that just married someone in the village
nearby but the Industrial Revolution
really complicated our love life and
today with affordable flights and online
social media people typically migrate
more than 100 kilometers from their
place of birth to find our soul mate so
now you might ask okay but who does the
hard work of migrating from places to
places to form families are these day
males or the females we used our data to
address this question and at least in
the last 300 years we found that the
ladies do the hard work of migrating
from places to places to form families
now these results are statistically
significant so you can take it a
scientific fact that males are lazy we
can move from questions about demography
and ask questions about human health for
example we can ask to what extent
genetic variations account for
differences in life span between
individuals
previous studies analyzed the
correlation of longevity between twins
to address this question they estimated
that the genetic variations account for
about quarter of the differences in life
span between individuals between can be
correlated due to so many reasons
including various environmental effects
or shared household large family trees
give us the opportunity to analyze both
close relatives such as twins all the
way to distant relatives even fourth
cousins this way we can build robust
models
that can tease apart the contribution of
genetic variations from environmental
factors we conducted this analysis using
our data and we found that genetic
variations explain only 15% of the
differences in lifespan between
individuals that is five years on
average so genes matter less than what
we thought before to lifespan and I find
it is great news because it means that
our actions can matter more smoking for
example determines ten years of our life
expectancy twice as much than margin
ethics determines we can even have more
surprising findings as we move from
family trees and we let our genealogists
to document and crowdsource DNA
information and the results can be
amazing it might be hard to imagine but
uncle Bernie and his friends can create
a DNA forensic capabilities that even
exceed what the FBI currently has when
you place the DNA on a large family tree
you effectively create a beacon that
illuminates the hundreds of distant
relatives that are all connected to the
person that originated the DNA by
placing multiple beacons on a large
family tree you can now triangulate the
DNA of an unknown person the same way
that the GPS system uses multiple
satellites to find a location the prime
example of the power of this technique
is capturing the Golden State killer one
of the most notorious criminals in the
history of the u.s. the FBI has been
searching for this person for over 40
years they had his DNA but he never
showed up in any police database about a
year ago the FBI consulted a genetic
genealogist and she suggested that they
will submit his DNA to a genealogy
service that can locate distant
relatives they did that and they found a
third cousin of the Golden State killer
they built a large family tree
scan the different branches of the tree
until they found a profile that exactly
matched what they knew about the Golden
State Killer the obtained DNA from this
person and found a perfect match to the
DNA they had in hand they arrested him
and brought him to justice after all
these years since then genetic
genealogists have started working with
local US law enforcement agencies to use
this technique in order to capture
criminals and only in the past six
months they were able to solve over 20
cold cases with this technique but
luckily we have people like Uncle Bernie
and his fellow genealogists these are
not amateurs with a self-serving hobby
these are citizen scientists with a deep
passion to tell us who we are and they
know that the past can hold the key to
the future thank you very much
[Applause]